you
rapist monster man is not taking this
baseball bat offer me
so if i have to keep swinging it and
hitting you so you can't take it off of
me
and maybe turn it back on me then that's
what's gonna happen and i just kept
swinging it until he stopped trying to
grab it
[Music]
what kind of kid were you when you were
growing up
um
active energetic confident
um outspoken i wasn't shy
i kind of i don't know i felt like a bit
of a protector around my friends that i
felt were vulnerable you know
and stuff like that bit of a defender if
you could say that you know
i don't know i was a type of teenager
that just wouldn't have it and i
wouldn't take anybody bullying me or
taking advantage of me or anything like
that and i didn't like people taking
advantage of anybody close to me neither
what would you say
was a turning point in your life
well it has to be in 2003 when i was 19
and
my best friend at the time
called me
he told me
that
him and his girlfriend he was with at
the time i've been going for a bit of a
rough patch not talking to each other
maybe for like a week or two you know on
and off sort of thing
but during that period of time when they
were going through their rough patch
she um his girlfriend
got raped by somebody
well she said to him
that
she was with
this guy in his house that she met
because his brother was in the house
with his girlfriend and other people
like friends around the house drinking
and maybe smoking listening to music in
the front room they were talking about
relationship things and stuff like that
so
apparently he wanted to
give her some privacy another
conversation in the bedroom so she went
with them took her drink in the bedroom
and then he closed the door
he forced himself on top of her
she told him to get off
he wouldn't stop
um he was saying things like i'm going
to tell you a man i'm [ __ ] you and
i'm taking you away from your man and
you'll put his mind nobody couldn't stop
me from doing this i'm going to do this
all the time and she was crying and
saying telling him to get off and he
wouldn't stop and he wouldn't get off
and she was terrified and scared so she
just let him do what he wanted to do
until he stopped
when my boy first told me
what happened i said to him
why didn't your girl go to the police
and he said she's scared to go to the
police
and she just wanted him to do something
to just stop this man from
you know
troubling her again
confronting her you know
how much did you know about this man
nothing much really
apart from that he was calling himself a
gang star from the area and uh
this is what he was telling her and she
was obviously relaying that to my boy
who related to me you know so we didn't
really know much he's called picking
himself up making himself seem tough i
said like i said gangster diss that and
the other he said you've got a lot of
guys working for him and stuff like that
so
to hear that on top of
what he already done
in my mind it was intimidating i was
like wow this guy he's doing a lot
so
he's not to be taken lightly you know
to approach this man with caution
he could be approaching somebody that's
done something so vicious so savage
so humanly you know
man's moving like an animal could
live like an animal with us
you could be walking into a situation
confronting this man but we all end up
hurt
or
even worse
it was my boy's plan and his girls plan
and what they done basically is
phone the man back
and she asked him to come and meet her
the plan was he was gonna pull up at the
bus stop what he did and meet her and
was in a phone box waiting for him
with two baseball bats
and when he did arrive
he came out the phone box we approached
him
um as he was talking to the girl
he saw us coming
um he grabbed a girl and held her
like as in like a shield so
automatically as well in my head i'm
thinking wow this guy he's done
something he knows what he's done
something wrong because why would you
see two people coming towards you even
if you see them with baseball bats in
your hand unless you've done something
wrong and got a guilty conscience why
are you gonna grab the female that
you've come
to um
uh to pick up and have fun with and have
sex with or whatever you're gonna do why
are you gonna grab her like that and
hold her like a shield you've done
something guilty my reaction was to hit
him with the back to get him off of the
girl my boy done the same thing hit him
a few times he let go of the girl
then obviously he was trying to disarm
me and take my battle for me
because at these times i think i call
these across the road smashing up the
car
um
i'm
tasking him with the man getting back
and forth he's trying to get the battle
for me i'm hitting him some more he
dropped on the floor and knee and then i
just ran across the road shouted to my
boy let's go we ran off
and
that was it basically
so when he left he was just on the
street he was just lying down on the
floor yeah i didn't leave him lying on
the floor he was on one knee like he
broke his fall and it was on one knee
what emotions were you going through
when you took that revenge it was more
just a human reaction thing in it you
rapist monster man is not taking this
baseball bat off of me so if i have to
keep swinging it and hitting you so you
can't take it off of me
and maybe turn it back on me then that's
what's going to happen and i just kept
swinging it until he stopped trying to
grab it
from where i lived at the time we could
see the
police put up the tent around his body
and all the road taped off
and stuff and um they were just there
for hours and that's why i started to
think this has probably gone way too far
because why is there a tent around him
when they just put him in ambulance and
take him off like what's going on
usually tent means
corpse
blue tape can't what what's going on is
this man dead he can't be dead i only
hit him a few times at the baseball bat
in the head and around the shoulder neck
and wherever else
you know but looking back on it again
how many times did i actually hit him he
said i don't know because it's in the
heat at the moment when you're swinging
and swinging and swinging
you don't know i'm not keeping count
it was about i don't know five or six
days later crime stoppers put
posters up around
the streets where it happened
um saying that the man had died is there
any information on this man
because he's not known to the police of
steve's in the country on a
illegal passport or whatever legal
immigrant whatever they call it um
so they wanted to know who he was and
any information so
there was a point where i kind of
accepted
if i get caught i'll get caught because
it is what it is and it must be part of
my destiny in it must be part of my fate
i've just accepted it in it like yeah
i've done the crime i don't care if i
got to do the time i'd do it in it so
at least i can say i know what i've done
you know and i know what reason i've
done it for
how did it feel in that moment to
actually realize that you've killed
someone
um
to this day you know it's a strange
feeling
sometimes you don't really
know what that feeling is but it's there
it's hard to explain
no no
you feel bad about yourself and only
question yourself
like i'm a bad person i'm a good person
you know am i wrong am i right
i know i'm a religious person as well so
i think it's in the hands of god in it
forgot to judge me no one else
so how did you get
called how did you get arrested
and it's about a month after or
something like that then all of my door
my colleague's door my sister's door
police kicked off about five or six
doors simultaneously
and just arrested all of us on murder
our suspicion of murder the court
hearing was hard you know for me because
all i'm thinking is
i just want this jury to hear from the
girl
so they can put their self in my shoes
and feel like how i felt that night
you know and be like well are you going
to go out and help this girl
and tell this rapist man to stay away
from her or you just
kind of sit on your hands and do nothing
so the jury they were asking
where the girl is in our trial because
she was excluded from our trial
she's got a plea bargain for conspiracy
to assault
she's the per the reason why i heard
this guy why this all started obviously
we're not gonna hear from the guy we
need to hear from her
and they didn't get to hear from her so
it was difficult for me you know
sitting in there
as a young black man i thought oh my god
i'm already on the back foot
yeah i just had to just just sit there
and just take it all in and then
sometimes when your barrister isn't
saying what you want him to say and
fighting for you how you want him to
fight then you know you can't really
jump up in the court and
start saying no you didn't say that
right supposed to say this and say that
because obviously it compromises your
character you're gonna have old jewelry
looking at you like it's some savage and
you're not trying to be a savage eye
you're just trying to be a normal person
and then there was another part of the
trial where
me and my co-defendant
could have been um given
a manslaughter charge a deal by the
prosecution but my co-defendant didn't
want to accept the manslaughter
so they said if we're not having both of
them on the man's score
then it's nothing at all they can both
stay on the murder charge
so i was pissed i was mad at my
co-defendant i was like why are you
taking the lesser charge
this manslaughter means
you can go home soon five ten years or
whatever it's not a life sentence if you
go down for murder that's life sentence
life
license always going to be on your ass
until you're dead
what was your sentence
it was 12 years
but i did eight months i'm a man so the
judge ended up he sentenced me to 11
years and 127 days
it's only 19 at the time i'll get out
when i'm 30 something
what was the first night in prison like
um
you can't really only personally i
couldn't really sleep all the noise
smell
you know so many things going for your
brain about what's gonna happen the next
day
the next month the next years
what was the hardest thing for you in
jail
um
that's missing my family really missing
my family yeah
yeah
visits and that when they send you far
to these country joes and you're from
london and your family can't make it
there and
stuff like that you know or even getting
ghosted that's the worst you're looking
forward to a visit and go and sit on the
visit
if it's on sometimes two hours hour 45
minutes you get out there early
you know i mean after shaved up fresh
trim and that you know i mean some these
girls can only wear prison shirts you
spend time ironing out your prison shirt
and stuff like that you're sitting there
no one's coming
no one's coming
no one's coming people start offering
you drinks and that oh you want a drink
want something to eat you're like nah
i'm all right my people will be soon no
one's coming no one's coming and
officers are like sorry mate you want to
go back to the wing you're so
embarrassed and it's hurtful it's a
ghosting you know because you put so
much energy and
you know that emotion into looking
forward to your visit and you don't get
it it's horrible
it's horrible
especially when you're supposed to go on
a visit and get some to make your night
more easier you know and bless up the
man and wondering and it don't happen
it's horrible
i wonder how you were treated in prison
by other inmates do you think their
attitude is different when you're
serving time for murder
in my circumstances
everyone i've met to this day can
condone what i've done because they say
what you killed a rapist
fair play to you mate
would have done the same thing i've had
governors tell me that i've had
um the wing officers told me that you
know
number one governors of the prison
telling me that they would have done the
same thing or telling me they would have
done worse to the guy and stuff like
that so
i don't know if i suppose that gave me a
more easier time in prison you know
people just had nothing but
respect for what i've done you know
because everyone's got a mother or a
sister or a daughter you know
oh well it's the system that's [ __ ]
they should have never locked you up
that's what most people say to me how
can they lock you up what you done
i mean person i just took each day as it
come
and luckily for me just being confident
you know
i got through it all right
i'm out and i've been out for about what
a year and a half now been doing one and
two jobs here construction maybe a
little deliveries here and there
concentrating on my music you know
and yes all right this time
no going back i'm here and talking to
you so yeah it's getting all right so
far it's all good tonight fingers
crossed that they say
have ever seen your friend or his
girlfriend after what happened no i
haven't you know
i haven't i haven't
and you know i don't even know how i'd
feel if
if i was to see them to bump into them i
wouldn't
i wouldn't even know what to say i'd be
speechless like
so much to say but
so much i just wouldn't want to say i
just want to carry with my life and
don't even
probably go back there man
do you have any regrets about what you
do
no i don't know
because
i believe what i done was right
for my heart
the girlfriend i was with at the time
when she saw the murder
poster go up in the area she said i know
that guy's face
before i met you a year ago i was in her
hairdresser's and half of it's a barbers
and at the back of the toilet i went out
about to use the toilet that guy did he
followed me into the toilet shut the
door behind and said give me some [ __ ]
i said no and he wouldn't let me go
get at the bathroom and i said if you
don't move i'm gonna scream and then he
let me at the bathroom i said what that
same guy she said yeah i said are you
sure she said yes i'm sure
him
i said wow
look at that for a coincidence
so
putting that
with what happened to my co-defendant's
girlfriend
made me feel
like there's too many
things pointing towards this guy
being
a pedophile rapist scumbag
so
i've looked it in my head time and time
and time and time and time again over
and over and over again am i wrong am i
right
and i feel like i don't know i feel like
yeah i'm kind of right
there's one less rapist on the earth
and that's got to be a good thing
do you think it's the right thing to
take power in your own hands in this
sense or do you think we should aim at
the police to address this
the police
officer got raped um and raped and
murdered a girl the other day
how can you go to the police
a police officer was convicted for
raping and killing a girl the other day
right
so where are we going with this the
police are doing the same things so how
can you go to the police
hmm i can girls go to the police they're
going to go to their boyfriends they're
going to go to their friends they're
going to go to their brothers they're
going to go to their dads
you're going to go to somebody that's
probably going to do something about it
straight away and not be like um we're
going to investigate and give you a
crime number and get back to you and you
you're scared to go to the shops now
you can't go at your house
scared
how much women out there have been raped
and violated and and and kids have been
violated by pedophiles and that
ask them how they feel
about people like that whether we should
take the law into our own hands and um
sometimes dish out our own justice
if it's a
monster then you know
i'm not really haunted by that you know
would you would you do the same thing
for your friend for your mom for your
sister for your brother
no
no i mean she makes us question our own
selves and it's humans in it
would you do the same thing again
if i was put in that situation again
i have a defending i'm a defender
if i have to live my life in prison
being a defender then that's what i'm
gonna have to do and then if i have to
die in prison being a defender then i'm
gonna die in prison being a defender and
at least i can live in myself and myself
and say i defended something for the
right reason
[Music]
i just was hoping that you wouldn't
want to have sex with me
and then
they um but he did so but i just
i think like i thought in my own mind
that
this was it now